que, como todos sabemos,
es el sello distintivo de cada lugar de trabajo estadounidense.
Hay miles de imágenes como estas.
Solo pongan "madre trabajadora" en imágenes de Google,
guarden el sitio de fotos.
Están por toda Internet,
llenan los blogs y las noticias,
y me he obsesionado con ellas y la mentira que nos dicen
y la comodidad que nos dan,
que cuando se trata de la nueva maternidad de trabajo en EE.UU.,
todo está bien.
Pero no está bien.
Como país, estamos enviando a millones de mujeres a trabajar
todos los años, increíble y horriblemente pronto
después de dar a luz.
Este es un problema moral
pero hoy también diré por qué es un problema económico.
Me molestó mucho y me obsesioné con la irrealidad de estas imágenes,
que no se parecen en nada a mi vida,
que recientemente decidí lanzar y protagonizar una parodia de fotografías
que esperaba el mundo empezara a usar
simplemente mostrando la realidad muy incómoda de volver a trabajar
cuando la fuente de alimentación de tu bebé está conectada a tu cuerpo.
Solo voy a mostrar dos.
(Risas)
Nada dice "Da a esa chica una promoción", al tener fugas de leche materna
en su vestido durante una presentación.
Se darán cuenta de que no hay bebé en esta foto,
porque no es así como funciona esto,
no para la mayoría de las madres trabajadoras.
¿Sabían, y esto va a arruinar su día,
que cada vez que pasan un inodoro, el contenido se vuelve un aerosol
y se quedará en el aire durante horas?
Y, sin embargo, para muchas madres trabajadoras,
este es el único lugar durante el día, en que pueden hacer la comida
para sus recién nacidos.
Puse estas cosas, unas 12, en el mundo.
Quería plantear una idea.
No sabía que también estaba abriendo una puerta,
porque ahora, extrañas de todos los ámbitos de la vida
me escriben todo el tiempo
solo para decirme lo que es para ellas volver al trabajo
días o semanas después de tener un bebé.
Voy a compartir 10 historias con Uds. hoy.
Son totalmente reales, algunas son muy crudas,
y ninguna se parece a esto.
Aquí está la primera.
"Yo era un miembro en servicio activo en una prisión federal.
Volví al trabajo tras el máximo permitido a 8 semanas de mi cesárea.
A un compañero de trabajo le molestó que hubiera estado de 'vacaciones'
por lo que intencionalmente abrió la puerta mientras estaba sacándome leche
y se quedó en la puerta con los reclusos en el pasillo".
Muchas historias que mujeres totalmente desconocidas, me envían,
no son en realidad sobre la lactancia materna.
Una mujer me escribió para decir:
"Di a luz a los gemelos y volví al trabajo tras 7 semanas sin pago.
Emocionalmente, era una ruina.
Físicamente, tuve una hemorragia grave durante el parto, un gran desgarro,
así que apenas podía levantarme, sentarme o caminar.
Mi empleador me dijo que no podía usar mis días de vacaciones disponibles
porque era época de presupuesto".
He llegado a creer que no podemos mirar situaciones como estas
porque nos horrorizaríamos,
y si nos horrorizamos entonces tenemos que hacer algo.
Así que optamos por mirar, y creer en esta imagen.
Realmente no sé qué está pasando en esta foto,
porque me parece raro y un poco espeluznante.
(Risas)
Como, ¿qué está haciendo?
Pero sé lo que nos dice.
Nos dice que todo está bien.
Esta madre trabajadora, todas las madres que trabajan y sus hijos, están bien.
No hay nada que ver aquí.
Y, de todos modos, las mujeres han tomado una decisión,
por lo que ninguno de sus problemas son nuestros.
Quiero dividir esta cosa de la elección en dos partes.
La primera opción dice que las mujeres han optado por trabajar.
Eso no es cierto.
Hoy en EE.UU., las mujeres representan el 47 % de la fuerza laboral,
y en el 40 % de los hogares de EE.UU.
una mujer es el sostén único o principal.
Nuestro trabajo remunerado es una parte enorme del motor de esta economía,
y es esencial para los motores de nuestras familias.
A nivel nacional, el trabajo remunerado no es opcional.
La número dos dice que las mujeres optan por tener hijos,
así que las mujeres solas deben afrontar las consecuencias.
Ya saben, esa es una de esas cosas
que si la escuchas de paso, puede sonar correcta.
No te hice tener un bebé.
Desde luego, no estaba allí cuando pasó.
Pero esa postura ignora una verdad fundamental,
que es que nuestra procreación a escala nacional no es opcional.
Los bebés que las mujeres, muchas de ellas trabajadoras, están teniendo hoy,
un día serán nuestra fuerza de trabajo, protegerán nuestras costas,
conforman nuestra base de impuestos.
Nuestra procreación a escala nacional no es opcional.
Esas no son opciones.
Necesitamos mujeres en el trabajo. Necesitamos que tengan bebés.
Así que debemos hacer esas cosas al mismo tiempo
al menos apetecibles, ¿no?
Bueno, es el momento de un examen sorpresa:
¿Qué porcentaje de mujeres que trabajan en EE.UU.
no tienen acceso a permiso remunerado por maternidad?
88 %.
Al 88 % de las madres que trabajan no se les paga un minuto de tiempo
después de tener un bebé.
Así que ahora están pensando en las licencias no remuneradas.
Existe en EE.UU. Se llama FMLA. No funciona.
Debido a que está estructurada con todo tipo de excepciones,
la mitad de las madres no son elegibles para ella.
Este es su aspecto.
"Adoptamos nuestro hijo.
Cuando recibí la llamada, el día en que nació, tuve que dejar de trabajar.
No había estado el tiempo suficiente para calificar para FMLA,
así que no era elegible para la licencia sin sueldo.
Cuando tomé un tiempo para conocer a mi hijo recién nacido,
perdí mi trabajo".
Estas fotografías esconden otra realidad, otra capa.
De las que sí tienen acceso a solo esa licencia sin sueldo,
la mayoría no pueden darse el lujo de tomar mucho tiempo.
Una enfermera me dijo: "Yo no califico para la discapacidad a corto plazo
porque mi embarazo se considera una condición preexistente.
Usamos todas las devoluciones de impuestos y la mitad de los ahorros
en seis semanas no pagadas.
No podía soportar más tiempo.
Físicamente era difícil, emocionalmente fue peor.
Luché durante meses al estar lejos de mi hijo".
Así que esta decisión de volver a trabajar tan pronto,
es una decisión económica racional impulsada por las finanzas de la familia,
pero a menudo es físicamente horrible
porque traer un ser humano al mundo es complicado.
Una camarera me dijo:
"Con mi primer bebé, volví al trabajo 5 semanas después del parto.
Con el segundo, tuve una cirugía mayor después de dar a luz,
así que esperé hasta 6 semanas para volver.
Tenía lágrimas de tercer grado".
El 23 % de las nuevas madres trabajadoras en EE.UU.
estará de vuelta al trabajo a las dos semanas de dar a luz.
"He trabajado como camarera y cocinera, 75 horas a la semana durante el embarazo.
Tuve que volver a trabajar antes del primer mes,
a trabajar 60 horas a la semana.
Una de mis compañeras solo pudo pagar 10 días de descanso con su bebé".
Claro, esto no es solo un escenario con consecuencias económicas y físicas.
El parto es, y siempre será, un enorme evento psicológico.
Una profesora me dijo:
"Volví a trabajar 8 semanas después del nacimiento de mi hijo.
Yo ya sufro de ansiedad,
pero los ataques de pánico que tenía antes de volver eran insoportables".
Estadísticamente hablando,
cuanto menor la licencia después de tener un bebé,
es más probable sufrir trastornos del ánimo posparto
como depresión y ansiedad,
y entre muchas potenciales consecuencias de esos trastornos,
el suicidio es la segunda causa más común de muerte
en mujeres después del primer año del parto.
Atención a la siguiente historia.
Nunca he conocido a esta mujer, pero me resulta difícil de asimilar:
"Siento tremenda pena y rabia de perder un elemento esencial,
un tiempo insustituible y formativo con mi hijo.
El trabajo y parto me dejó absolutamente devastada.
Durante meses, todo lo que recuerdo son gritos por cólicos, dijeron.
Por dentro me estaba ahogando.
Todas las mañanas, me pregunté cuánto tiempo más podría hacerlo.
Se me permitió llevar a mi bebé al trabajo.
Cerré la puerta de mi oficina mientras lo mecía y callaba
y le rogué que dejara de gritar para no meterme en problemas.
Me escondí en la oficina cada maldito día
y lloraba mientras él gritaba.
Lloré en el baño mientras lavaba el equipo de bombeo.
Cada día, lloraba de camino al trabajo y a la vuelta.
Le prometí a mi jefe que el trabajo que no hiciera durante el día,
lo haría en la noche en la casa.
Pensé, hay algo mal en mí que no puedo manejar esto".
Así que esas son las madres.
¿Qué hay de los bebés?
Como país, ¿nos preocupamos por los millones de bebés
nacidos de madres que trabajan?
Yo digo que no, no hasta que
tengan edad de trabajar, pagar impuestos y hacer el servicio militar.
Les decimos te veremos en 18 años,
y llegar allí es cosa de ellos.
Lo sé porque los bebés cuyas madres
tienen 12 o más semanas en casa con ellos
tienen más probabilidades de tener las vacunas y chequeos del primer año,
por lo que estarán más protegidos de enfermedades mortales e incapacitantes.
Pero esas cosas se ocultan detrás de imágenes como esta.
EE.UU. tiene un mensaje para las nuevas madres que trabajan y para sus bebés.
Cualquiera sea el tiempo que pasen juntos, deben estar agradecidas por ello,
son un inconveniente
para la economía y para sus empleadores.
Esa narrativa de gratitud aparece en muchas de las historias que escucho.
Una mujer me dijo:
"Volví a las 8 semanas después de mi cesárea
porque mi marido estaba sin trabajo.
Sin mí, mi hija tuvo retraso en el desarrollo.
No tomaba su biberón.
Empezó a perder peso.
Afortunadamente, mi jefe fue muy comprensivo.
Dejó que mi mamá trajera a mi bebé,
que estaba con oxígeno y un monitor,
cuatro veces para que yo pudiera cuidarla".
Hay un pequeño club de países en el mundo
que no ofrecen ninguna licencia nacional pagada a las nuevas madres.
¿Adivinan cuáles son?
Los 8 primeros suman 8 millones en población total.
Son Papúa Nueva Guinea, Surinam y las pequeñas naciones insulares
de Micronesia, Islas Marshall, Nauru, Niue, Palau y Tonga.
El número nueve es Estados Unidos de América,
con 320 millones de personas.
Oh, eso es todo.
Ese es el final de la lista.
Cualquier otra economía del planeta
ha encontrado una forma de dar alguna licencia nacional remunerada
para la gente que hace el trabajo del futuro de esos países,
pero nosotros decimos: "No podríamos hacer eso".
Decimos que el mercado resolverá este problema,
y nos animamos cuando las empresas ofrecen licencia y atención a las mujeres
que ya tienen mejor instrucción y reciben mejor paga.
¿Recuerdan ese 88 %?
Esas mujeres de medianos y bajos ingresos no van a participar en eso.
Conocemos los asombrosos costos económicos, financieros, físicos
y emocionales de este enfoque.
Hemos decidido, decidido, no es un accidente,
pasar estos costos directamente a las madres trabajadoras y a sus bebés.
Sabemos que el precio es mayor para mujeres de bajos ingresos,
y de manera desproporcionada para las mujeres de color.
Se los pasamos de todos modos.
Todo esto para vergüenza de EE.UU.
Pero también para riesgo de EE.UU.
Debido a lo que sucedería
si todas estas llamadas opciones personales de tener bebés
empezaran a convertirse en elecciones personales de no tener bebés.
Una mujer me dijo:
"La nueva maternidad es dura. No debería ser traumática.
Al hablar de expandir nuestra familia ahora,
nos centramos en el tiempo que tendría que cuidarme y al nuevo bebé.
Si tuviera que hacerlo de nuevo de la misma forma que con el primero,
podríamos seguir con un niño".
La tasa de natalidad necesaria para mantener la población estable
es de 2,1 nacimientos por mujer.
En EE.UU. hoy, estamos en 1,86.
Necesitamos que las mujeres tengan hijos,
y estamos desincentivando activamente a las mujeres que trabajan de hacer eso.
¿Qué le pasaría a la fuerza laboral, a la innovación, al PIB,
si una a una, las madres trabajadoras de este país deciden
que no pueden soportar la idea de hacer esto más de una vez?
Estoy aquí hoy con una sola idea que vale la pena difundir,
y han adivinado cuál es.
Ha pasado mucho tiempo para que el país más poderoso del planeta
ofrezca la licencia nacional remunerada
a las personas que hacen el trabajo del futuro de este país
y para los bebés que representan ese futuro.
El parto es un bien público.
Esta licencia debe ser subsidiada por el Estado.
No debería haber ninguna excepción por ser pequeña empresa,
por duración del empleo ni por emprendimiento.
Se debería poder compartir en la pareja.
He hablado hoy mucho de las madres,
pero los padres son importantes en muchos niveles.
Ni una sola mujer más debería tener que volver a trabajar
mientras que está cojeando y sangrando.
Ni una familia más debería tener que vaciar su cuenta de ahorros
para comprar un par de días de descanso, recuperación y vinculación.
Ningún frágil bebé
debería tener que ir de la incubadora a la guardería
porque sus padres han agotado todo su magro tiempo
sentados en la UCIN.
A ninguna familia trabajadora más le deberían decir que la colisión
de su trabajo, su trabajo necesario y su paternidad necesaria,
es solo problema de ellos.
La trampa es que cuando esto le pasa a una nueva familia, se está consumiendo,
y una familia con un nuevo bebé es financieramente más vulnerable
que nunca antes,
por lo que la nueva madre no puede darse el lujo de tener voz propia.
Pero todos tenemos voz.
Yo ya he terminado, ya tuve mis bebés.
Uds. quizá estén por tener,
o hayan tenido ya,
o no tengan bebé.
No debería importar.
Tenemos que dejar de enmarcar esto como un tema de la madre,
o un asunto de mujeres.
Este es un tema de EE.UU.
Tenemos que dejar de comprar la mentira que nos muestran estas imágenes.
Tenemos que dejar de ser consolados por ellas.
Tenemos que preguntarnos por qué dicen que no puede funcionar
cuando vemos que funciona en todas partes del mundo.
Tenemos que reconocer que esta realidad de EE.UU.
es para nuestra deshonra y para nuestro propio riesgo.
Debido a que esto no es,
esto no es,
y este no es el aspecto de una madre trabajadora.
(Aplausos)